imaginemos el siguiente escenario
imaginemos que queremos obtener un
préstamo con un principal un principal p
de 50 pesos y que lo vamos a pagar en un
tiempo de tres años también imaginemos
que vamos a durante esos tres años tener
cuatro periodo de imposición del interés
que cuatro periodos en un año perdón
cuatro periodos en un año de imposición
del interés y finalmente vamos a
imaginar que la tasa de interés a la que
vamos a prestar este dinero vamos a
ponerle r porque yo se la t r es del 10%
el 10% anual o lo que es lo mismo el
0.10 bien entonces como podría escribir
una fórmula para calcular cuánto voy a
tener que pagar al final de todo este
periodo pues de ambos
de hecho aquí ya tengo una fórmula
bastante similar lo que voy a hacer es
tener un principal de 50 pesos 50 pesos
que voy a multiplicar por 1
uno más mi tasa de interés que es 0.10
0.10
dividido entre el número de periodos de
imposición por año entre 4
elevado a la potencia 4 porque si voy a
tener cuatro periodos de imposición en
cada año pero voy a hacerlo a lo largo
de tres años así que también tengo que
multiplicar este exponente por tres en
total
voy a tener 12 periodos ley de
imposición voy a compilar o componer mi
interés 12 veces incluso si quisieran lo
podríamos escribir en términos más
exactos como una fórmula para mi
principal x 1 siempre voy a tener este 1
+ la tasa de interés anual la tasa de
interés anual dividida entre el número
de periodos de imposición m
y todo esto elevado a la potencia n por
donde t es el número de años en los que
pienso pagar el crédito ahora lo
interesante aquí es pensar qué sucede
cuando el número de periodos de
imposición crece exorbitantemente vamos
a pensar que esto es el límite comenzar
en tratar de encontrar el límite cuando
emitiendo infinito de esta expresión de
aquí y bien como sería eso pues veamos
vamos a tratar de reescribir esto para
empezar tengo esta constante para que
pueda sacar del límite y escribir esto
como p veces de veces el límite cuando m
tiende infinito
mi mente cuando entiende infinito
por perdón
uno más
la taza r
dividida entre el número de periodos de
imposición
y toda esta expresión elevado a la
potencia n
ok ahora necesito transformar esto en
una cosa que yo conozca y yo conozco
este límite yo sé que todo este límite
de aquí que tengo del vídeo pasado vale
así que lo que voy a hacer es definir
una nueva variable x
no se definieron la variable x
que va a estar definida como x va a ser
el inverso de este número así que va a
ser n / r n / r o lo que es lo mismo
vamos a escribirlo como
n va a ser igual
x
x por ver ahora si en sí en ese b
infinito como r es una constante r está
fija si en ese infinito porque estoy
calculando límite cuando entiende
infinito entonces x también debe irse
infinito por lo tanto puede escribir
esto como
por el límite quizás debería usar otro
color vamos a usar rojo límite cuando x
tiende a infinito
te quiero
pues usando mi sustitución
usando mi sustitución x es igual a entre
r voy a escribir esto como uno más
r / n es simplemente un mantra x así que
voy a escribir esto como uno /
x
elevado a la potencia en el porte pero n
es x por r así que x
r
por qué
ahora bien esto ya se está apareciendo
mucho a la expresión que tenía en el
límite de la distribución de e pero
necesito sacar este exponente esta parte
del exponente de hecho déjenme copio
esto
confío en este caso de aquí
copio
y vamos a escribir de nuevo
x
ahora voy a poner unos paréntesis aquí
el límite y lo tengo copiado espera
p por este límite acá
cierro mis paréntesis
y si tengo un exponente que es el
producto de varios números es lo mismo
que
este caso aquí elevado a la potencia r
x
y esto obviamente no está siendo muy
riguroso pero lo que me interesa es
darles la idea intuitiva de por qué está
sucediendo esto
y ahora lo que estoy haciendo aquí es
realmente utilizando el hecho de que si
tengo el límite cuando x tiende a
infinito de una función f de x
a la potencia de clips con el reporte
donde esté son constantes
esto va a ser lo mismo que
límite cuando x tiende a infinito
efe de x a la equis y todo eso elevado a
la potencia que reporte eso es lo que
está detrás de esta fórmula de aquí pero
bueno ahora si esto de aquí cuánto es
pues yo sé cuánto vale yo sé que este
límite vale
este límite vale así que en realidad lo
que tengo es
por e
por la constante e elevada a la potencia
r
por ti y esto es una fórmula para la
cantidad que tendría que pagar si tengo
un préstamo con un principal pe y el
interés se está componiendo
constantemente de manera continua a lo
largo de t años a una tasa de r anual
vamos a hacer un ejemplo concreto creo
que eso tratará las cosas vamos a
imaginar que tenemos un préstamo por 150
pesos con un principal de 50 pesos que
vamos a apoyar a lo largo de tres años
con una tasa de interés anual del 10 por
ciento y vamos a tener 14 periodos de
imposición al año sino una cantidad
infinita de periodos de imposición el
interés se va a estar componiendo
continuamente entonces cuánto tendríamos
que pagar al final de todo esto pues
tendríamos que pagar
nuestro principal que son 50 pesos por
nuestra fórmula de acá nos dice que por
la exponencial
que alá
nuestra tasa de interés que es de 0.10
0.10 por el tiempo el tiempo está en
años son tres años
y nos dan 67 punto 49 vamos a decir 67
49 pesos es el total que tendríamos que
pagar después de esos tres años con esa
tasa de interés